on a une info sur shine parce que tout
au long de l'émission il ya des infos
qui sont destinés comme ça ouvrez
l'oreille weekes espace alors je la
donne l'info maintenance ah oui fait dix
jours que j'aurai des moments jamais je
veux te parler ans sa fille transmettre
que tu dois donner
tu vas mettre de la fisa sinon je te
jure je servais tous les ponts soleil de
paris la série profilage a démarré sur
tf1 profilage avec philippe maes vous
savez que juliette roues desquelles
actuelle actrice que l'on voit
actuellement sur la saison de tf1 elle
s'en va de sa propre volonté quitte la
série mais qui va la remplacer les amis
[Rires]
de venir millimes attise trois mois que
shine va faire le premier 11 rien
j'avais bel âge personne ne le sait moi
je les subis par les gens du casting
non oui oui parce que j'ai fait c'est
faire confiance et m'a dit t'as qu'à
balancer mais même charme de la pas dit
non plus
sur mes clips et tu vas te re profilage
elle se tourne t
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chez elle à saint gobain qui lui
dit quelque chose tu m'offres qu'est ce
qui se passe chez rim je mange pas ce
soir sans déconner j'adore énorme effort
est pour une fois il avait loué je veux
te dire il n'ya pas prendre la place de
quelqu'un m'appelle je peux je termine
en disant qu'au casting a été
remarquable tout de suite
alors on s'est privé pas nous dire au
casting qu'elle est maintenant 14 ans
mais la notoriété parfois ils engagent
des gens qui sont pas très bons mais
sorti son célèbre dôme il arrivait dans
sous le soleil
il a joué cinq ans neuf sous le soleil
ou le soleil ailleurs souhaitiez lui aie
ça sur france 2 la question revient le
lendemain et époque
[Rires]
j'ai raté une très bonne et il y avait
un mec qui va pas d'ariel je coupais
john parry quoi il a fait tous les
métiers mi mai jurés comédienne est ce
qu'elle arrête sa carrière de chanteuse
pour autant mais non pas du tout elle
est toujours sous contrat ou barnes est
un poil à gratter comme personne et la
nuit et cerné concert faute de
spectateurs vers aujourd'hui lé centre
avoir l'air drôle non mais je faisais
quoi allez sortez
tu sais